congratulations on this movie it was
really
well it was intense it was heartbreaking
at times and leading audiences sort of
all through the twists and turns
jake how were you able to achieve all of
that with minimal uh interaction with
co-stars on set
i mean from the beginning the movie was
about you know the uh
we always knew it was gonna be about
sound design you know i mean
um
the performers were always gonna be it
was a movie that antoine and i spoke
pretty intensely about about
perception and about
how what we what we project on the
people that we can't see you know
from the sound
the tone of their voice all those things
and so
i was very aware that
you know
the sound was going to be sort of in the
for foreground
and over time and i would sort of even
those enclosures and things like that
would be
falling back into the background after a
while so i don't know i just listened
you know it was just about listening to
these wonderful performances that kept
coming through and we filmed everything
live so all the performances were live
with me
um
and it was easy when you work with
actors like that
yeah for sure antoine as a 911 operator
jake spent you know the majority of the
film on the phone how were you able to
elicit that type of emotional
conversation were they happening
as jake said they're in real time or
where they pre-recorded some of them and
how do you go about that
no the performances you see all uh real
time
real time absolutely yeah and that was
you know
to jake's credit that was
a lot of emotions come out of mistakes
and a lot of it comes out of just you
know
uh
obviously jake's performance but the
mistakes being the technical stuff that
would
glitch like you know
zoom things didn't work properly at
times in the beginning because we were
figuring it all out right it was all
like a trial testing thing with actors
in uh australia and new york and all
that so
yeah so sometimes
you know jake was just in it so deep
there would be his voice in his ear
another actor's voice and their echoes
so he was hearing a performance
so you know
jake's an intense guy i mean i know him
really well he gets intense in his days
where i just know it was driving him
crazy but he never broke
character
but you know so a lot of things were it
was all happening
and then we were dealing with covet
and that was stressful and every time he
came on the set
uh
people off camera got to wear a mask but
he didn't so he was exposed to real
danger right so
that also brings a lot of um
uh intensity you know so
uh a lot of the emotion you see is it's
just jake's own his performance and
everything he does
as well as him bringing in the world
around him you know as a sponge so
you couldn't repeat that
yeah it was incredible i mean jake you
spent most of your time on a phone or on
a headset so in real life are you a
phone guy more of a texter or are you an
in-person conversation or a zoom guy
like what do you what do you like now
what's what's what's what's your ticket
uh well you know speaking of mistakes i
think we've all made them on text
message um yeah i think you know
communication can only be
only go so far like on a on a text chain
um
and so i i do prefer more important
conversations in person
um
and it's been harder and harder in these
periods of time so
obviously zoom has come into effect but
i i think sometimes i'm always very
interested in
um all the things going on inside my own
mind my own heart and in exchange with
people i love in my in the world and so
often i find myself avoiding phone calls
now and just going to a text do you
oh yeah you said it out loud now people
know it just goes to voicemail and
they're like he did it and it's not out
i think i'm not alone i think i'm not
alone um in fact i know i'm not because
i've gone to voicemail a lot of times
too
but i i will say that
i will say that i think the tendency now
for most people is to go i'll just text
that you know or i'll you know and i i
don't think that's a good thing at all i
prefer in person i prefer being in
person over phone calls over you know
well we're going to protect you right
now and we're just going to tell people
that normally if it goes it's just
you're busy and you're not avoiding them
right that's it
yeah so jake jake i really think that is
a very interesting
jake's not that much of a texture he
will blow your phone up until you get on
the phone believe me oh no really okay
yeah that's true with antoine i will
blow him up i'll be like but he'll know
and be like phone call
he's not gonna pick up i'll call again
you know all right
listen if you ever call us here at et
canada we promise we will pick up the
phone even though i have a question for
you are you a are you a whole full
texter like text the whole thing out and
then send or are you someone who's like
idea idea idea idea
i will send you pictures
and inspiration and then a full story
and then if i see you call i'll run to
the other room so i'm a little bit like
you i don't know what happened i don't
know it's awful wait wait wait this is
this is a character says it's not true i
do pick up the phone let's just
okay okay got it got it antoine you're
gonna have to you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to pack me up here oh
you do pick up the phone absolutely yeah
okay
grand one you do well i'm getting the
wrap here guys i could ask a million
more questions congratulations on the
movie so excited that it's premiering
here in tiff wish you were here in
person um but uh congratulations it's
getting fantastic buzz thank you so much
good to see you